on vous pose la question bien trouvé
l'amour sur internet il dangereux est-ce
qu'il y en a qui ont déjà essayé tient
autour de la table si en action oui bah
oui parce que je vis avec mon temps
c'est christiane chocat qui ont déjà
fait ce pas franchement il sait pas
voilà c'est pas scandale de faire ces
pas de tabou s'est amoindrie mais c'est
toujours eux tout est née entre eux la
vie est dangereuse même les rencontres
dans la vraie vie sont dangereuses aussi
mais on sent quelques joies de needham
ans pour il vous paraît sympa où des
tirs et de le revoir une fois suivant
est pas il révèle un tout autre visage
alors la scène que sur internet au
contraire on peut discuter longtemps
avant donc prendre ses précautions et
mieux connaître les missions justement
il disait qu'il y avait un il ya une
nana qui est tombé dans le panneau alors
justement mon temps avec une personne
sauf que c'était une personne qui avait
60 ans et elle s'autorise alors
justement qu'est-ce qu'elle co dangereux
pour une femme pour un homme aussi donc
la journaliste et à la raison moi je
suis une femme mais dangereux pour une
femme c'est sûr il tonné je voudrais
lieux publics échouer la journaliste
continue donc sa quête du grand amour a
pas qu'elle a rencontré à elle part à la
rencontre donc d'un jeune homme qui se
montrait très cash sur l'application
regardez c'est complètement ouf
franchement moi chez moi j'étais choqué
je vous dis que tu es chaud qui
charmante ça va
ça va très bien merci
thème est grosse comme ça un témoin
rendez vous je passe m'occuper de toi je
te mets des faits c'est moi quand on me
parle comme ça ça attise la curiosité
j'ai tout de suite envie de savoir qui
se cache derrière un ton aussi cache
cache cache à sa nature elle va me
prendre la tête derrière cette
application vraiment une pulsion avis
voilà presque dix ans carreaux blancs
moi même je n'ai pas dû être assez clair
ce soir là
tu t'es touché coquine et coquine en est
là
koussa
cerise sur le gâteau cette photo de son
sexe en érection envoyés sur mon
téléphone
alors voila moi le rêve et à tout ce
qu'on veut mais ça ça n'a rien à voir
c'est autre chose
oui c'est du sexe je confirme nos moeurs
nos mails à la voix et rencontre parce
qu'il ya des gens qui ont envie de
tomber amoureux donc bien sûr alors
c'est quoi le bon site
non mais je connais pas mais ça arrive
il est fait pour des rencontres souvent
du temps les mères voilées fait une
petite bêtise c'est quand je suis parti
en amérique je savais pas que c'était un
incident qui était mondiale donc j'étais
loin de chez moi donc je me suis inscrit
localement
sauf que ça s'est su à paris en fait
c'était la fan numéro combien je
répondrai pas mais le problème c'est que
j'ai été très embêtant pour moi parce
qu'on s'essuie assez vite mais j'ai vite
retirée vous êtes vous êtes susurré
nettement quand vous êtes dans un pays
il va pas se mentir c'est fait pour
combler avant une soirée et on fait des
rencontres
alors justement pour essayer de me
comprendre les attentes des utilisateurs
des utilisateurs les mictions s'est
également penché sur le profil de
certains adhérents parmi eux un jeune
homme qui explique son addiction à tin
d'heure et à ses envies de nouvelles
conquêtes regarder un camé de tender qui
n'a séduit qu'une quinzaine de femmes
mais qui passait ses journées à
fantasmer devant toutes les autres
terrible c'est vraiment le genre de
choses qu'il faut pas regarder parce que
tu te dis waouh mais tout ça c'est des
gens à rencontrer ce soit bien une fois
atteint le nombre de clics autoriser tin
d'or bloquer son accès pendant 12 heures
je me réveillais la nuit pour faire mais
mais mais swype autorisé parce que
j'étais arrivé au bout des douze heures
et que tu hinder manqué une notification
dix ans vous pouvez de nouveau lac est
sacré chez moi une tension nerveuse tels
que j'ai commencé de m'avoir de l'eczéma
est clairement de l'eczéma sur le 1 oui
las et fatigué qui s'abattit flamber
senna et amélie dans la façon qui soit
pour n'a l'impression qu'ils se
masturbant plus si besoin
c'est le mode métier pas du tout c'est
pas du tout méchant mais c'est que la
façon dont il parle de la chanson
l'impression que c'est une boulimie de
sexe qui est hyper flippante
donc moi je dis aux femmes qui veulent
s'inscrire là dessus n'y allez pas parce
que c'est dangereux on donne on a
tendance à donner rendez-vous dans un
café non c'est pas avec quoi le mec
revenir il peut être armé il peut venir
chez vous que votre argent sert à rien
si vous voulez trouver l'amour et
vitrines de alors vous j'ai manqué deux
très actifs sur les ailes à la balle
complet la cape et pinder
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les lola non mais c'est vrai que j'ai dû
dont vous parlez français talbot s'est
on est dedans on est dans un magasin
j'ai choisi mes bras car si on parle
d'égalité homme femme mais c'est
horrible ce que je vois là bas j'ai
l'impression d'être dans un billet sur
des sites comme ça dit la vérité autour
de la table on le saura jamais je vais
enquêter qu'il a déjà fait à part jean
michel qui a été moi j'ai su ce que la
vie nous ont offert un abonnement à vie
mais alors ouverte sur kindle sur foot
heures non monsieur sur aucun des deux
auteurs si on veut que des joueurs de
foot
si on est honnête on va bien se parler
honnêtement est-ce que sur instagram
oui donc c'est un peu par un peu on va
passer bien sûr certains dont je ne
connais plein de gens qui vont un peu
qu'ils vont un peu draguer des mecs ou
des meufs sur un star c'est devenu des
aspirations voilà ça se parle des
réseaux sociaux sont des sites de
rencontres ou par exemple par exemple
est-ce que vous avez déjà dragué sur un
star dit la vérité
voilà voilà au lieu de chasser quelqu'un
bah ouais tu vois la photo tu te vois
message privé bien sûr il est alors tu
habites dont tu habites tout mis en
scène excusez moi vous donniez votre
vraie photo et tout ça va être vraiment
évidemment si on sauve de nantes où les
gens savent que ça chineurs
c'est au coeur à chaque fois j'ai essayé
plusieurs fois dit à l'elfe on m'a
supprimé
on s'envole de l'identité de quelqu'un
d'autre n'ont jamais réussi à y aller
j'avais pensé pas casser moissac c'est
mon virus enveloppés l'identité si c'est
moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est déjà nouveaux badges a évoqué les
risques dans la démission mais vous
allez voir dans ce nouvel extrait des
choses peuvent parfois dérapé et est
allé beaucoup plus loin
la lie c'est un extrait qu'on voulait
absolument concret pour vous montrer et
vous dire d'être très très très
vigilants là tu regardes un homme
anthony la roche propose à des femmes
qui l'a séduite en ligne de coucher avec
lui si parmi elles sophie la trentaine
[Musique]
elle finit par accepter la proposition
du bel anthony la roche
problème il n'existe pas il s'agit en
fait d'un homme de plus de 60 ans + papy
que playboy mais sophie ne le voit pas
dans cet appartement
plongée dans le noir
la ddea bitouah mais le bandeau sur tes
yeux et il est venu me chercher il m'a
emmené dans la chambre et là il m'a
attaché les mains ou au lit et je
réalise que j'ai été violé parce que cet
homme là juge jamais donné mon accord
parce que c'est pas cette personne n'a
que j'allais voir
voilà c'est complètement fou un oui ça
alors je vous montrais juste un truc
après c'est que vous allez voir si cet
homme risque quelque chose et vous allez
voir que ça c'est fou hein bon à
l'époque isabelle s'en souvient sans
doute aussi sur minitel moi j'étais
beaucoup sur minitel a servi d'une fusée
avant sur minitel on faisait des
rencontres devrait rencontrer une femme
avec qui j'ai vécu 36 15 etc mais mais y
avait aussi des risques
je me souviens une fois je suis tombé
sur une paillasse adam k qui est tombée
sur vous c'est quand même le risque
numéro un tabou y avait des phénomènes à
ce que j'étais tombé sur eux parce que
je discutais beaucoup j'ai passé des
nuits c'était j'étais accro à l'époque
voilà dans les années 90 et j'étais
tombé sur une commissaire de police qui
m'avait fait peur parce qu'elle m'avait
dit je viens chez toi on parlait
beaucoup et me vient chez toi toutes
sirènes hurlantes avec ma voiture je te
met les menottes ont fait des trucs
dingues et j'avais franchement j'avais
pris peur j'avais dit non mais je
l'avais rencontrée après a pas d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais la suite on crise et ses 760 alors
regarder parce qu'on vous parlait de ce
papy est plus fou dans tout ça c'est que
les avocats précisent que ça va être
compliqué pour la jeune femme devrait
offert mes ballerines et oui vous allez
voir ça juste deviner ce que vous
pourriez vous aller sur des sites comme
ce nom non parce que d'abord j'essaie
vraiment et sage je me demande pourquoi
on n'y arrive pas c'est d'essayer de
rencontrer des gens dans la vraie vie
alors simplement de la drague mais par
exemple il faut faire un truc ça essayer
de faire un compliment une personne
qu'on ne connaît pas dans la rue après
les faits il n'y a pas en veine un
descendant du thalys
j'ai vu un monsieur j'ai regardé ses
shows suis je trouvais qu'elle était et
est très belle et je dis monsieur vous
avez les plus le tiff a été surpris mais
c'est vrai que je pense que ça peut
mettre des choses en place
mais c'est quand même mieux voir les
gens en face à face je serai pas
j'aurais pas envie je serais mal à
l'aise batterie tu pourrais toi
franchement pas du tout pas du tout
alors pas lui non pas du tout en plus je
suis alors là pour le compte qui
éviterait des bd parce que c'est pas ce
qui m'intéresse je trouve que c'est
formidable de se rencontrer comme ça moi
les le côté virtuel des choses le côté
on se connaît pas mais je comprends ce
que tu veux dire c'est un truc que je
peux pas faire enfin à la limite je peux
comprendre mais je vous écoute en tout
cela tu veux dit contente de compte j'ai
eu peur j'aurais eu peur si ma fille
paris voilà sa tribu là dessus je jeu
rue peur pour elle parce que quand même
les gars c'est ça supportable la façon
dont il est sain que je sais qu'il met à
madame b dane qui nous regarde et il
sait pas parce que votre fille est sûre
tajine point fr qu'elle fait des
rencontres
sachez le je vous rassure carmen alors
regardez pas ce que vous vous dites il
va il va se passer quelque chose pour ce
papy qui m'ont regardé ses avocats nous
explique
on est vraiment dans le cas d'un
fantasme sexuel qui était consenti dès
le début un de part et d'autre que ce
soit de la part de nos clients mais
également de la part des plaignantes
on a quand même le prototype quand même
d'un homme voyez sa mâchoire ses yeux
son regard ténébreux châtain aux yeux
bleus je pense que si on est normalement
dirigeants on ne peut se poser la
question de se dire à quel moment je
peux prétendre avoir comme quand maman
un mannequin donc voilà il n'y a rien à
faire là dessus qu'il avait fallu le
parisien la semaine dernière moi j'adore
les faits divers y avait une histoire
comme ça d'un couple qui s'était
rencontré sur teen d'heure ça va bien ça
s'est bien passé puis le mec a senti que
la fille avait un pet au casque
ouais donc il a rompu et depuis lui fait
le coup de glenn close dans liaison
fatale harcelé sa femme ses enfants et
ça c'est une histoire épouvantable mais
c'est fou mais c'est long mais je vous
dis c'est un message séparé de ses
ambitions
non je vais juste répondre en deux
secondes à francesca
je sais bien que l'époque est à dire
tous les angles sont des monstres etc
avec sur kindle ya autant de femmes que
d'hommes
il ya des femmes aussi qui passent leurs
soirées vis à vis des copines à ce but
est comme ça regardez les photos des
mecs c'est pas un truc de mecs si on a
tendance à dire c'est que les sommets on
navigue dans l'année que c'était plus
dangereux pour les femmes est moins de
précautions à prendre
évidemment comme dangereux j'ai aussi
qu'elle soit chez marthe de voir
derrière l'écran qu'on boîte mais bon
taf avait quitté le parc derrière
l'écran je vous dis ah oui il ya un mec
qui marmonne depuis tout à l'heure ses
patientes indoor pour moi c'est très
dangereux c'est évidemment attention et
puis c'est là où vivent haut et fort il
faut dire aux gens qui ont regardé aux
plus jeunes les travaux qui se mourait
oui mais bien sûr tu peux pas mais dans
la vraie lame de rafraîchir à des
garçons boîte qui lui sont reprochés
mois ce qui passait mal
alors que l'albanie car en corse avec on
a rien compris mais merci quand même
yamada m'épargner merci quand même
alors on va avoir 15 ans vous avez
répondu là-dessus trouvé l'amour sur
internet est il dangereux
merci oui à 68